[Musik]
in Wels beim panzerbatten 14 und die der
Frechheit in Ding kurz wo er drei Matte
vorstellen gleich vorweg dieses Fahrzeug
wird von der Firma KMW hergestellt ist
die gleiche Firma die auch unseren
Leopard 2 A4 herstellt dieses Fahrzeug
ist in drei Parts geteilt zu einem der
Triebwerksraum dann die Sicherheitszelle
oder auch Fahrerraum genannt und der
Arbeitsraum
ist verbaut ein Vierzylinder reinmotor
mit Direkteinspritzung und Abgas
Turbolader einen Hubraum von 4,8 Liter
wir haben einen 200 Liter passenden Tank
da wo es uns eine Reichweite im Gelände
gibt wo ca 600 km und auf der Straße vor
ca 1000 km
wir gingen weiter zu unserer
Sicherheitszelle unser Sicherheitszelle
ist Beschuss sicher ja mein Herzer bis
zu einem kaliberfond 7,62 mal 51 mm und
hält eine Sprengsatz von 8 Kilo DnD aus
das heißt wenn du was die turniert
passiert der Besatzung nichts wir haben
oben verbaut eine waffenstation das ist
baugleich diese Station die auch auf
unsere anderen gefechtfahrzeugen
Temperatur und den Husar oder den häkeln
verbaut ist
diese Wochenstation hat eine Bewaffnung
vor einem überschweren Maschinengewehr
mit einem Kaliber von 12,7 mm mit einer
mehrfach wurfanlage die
optikeinrichtungen sind eine Taxis
Kamera ein Wärmebildgerät und zur
Entfernung Messung haben wir ein Leser
Entfernungsmesser drauf
und jetzt schauen wir uns einmal das
Fahrzeug von innen aus
dem Fahrerplatz dieser Fahrerplatz
unterscheidet sich wie vor am normalen
LKW weil der Dingo ist auf ein
vorgestellt wo an u4000 den Unimog der
was er bei uns beim Bundesheer
eingeführt ist bisafan Besonderheit wir
haben eine
reifenfüllanlage ich kann auf Knopfdruck
den Reifendruck den Gelände anpassen und
kommt somit überall hin wir haben mal
Rückfahrkamera das hier geht wo es
hinter mir passiert
hinter mir ist der bordschützenplatz der
bordschutz ist dafür verantwortlich dass
er die Waffe steuert einen hinter den
Feuerkampf auf und meldet wann irgendwo
Station
und somit sie geht das gleiche aus der
Rechtsschutz wirkt und Steuer
und jetzt gehen wir noch hinten und
schauen uns unseren speziellen
werkstättenaufbau
und übrigens
Fahrzeug von hinten nach
jetzt haben wir an den besonderen Teil
von unserem Dingo an Kummer an den
werkstattaufbau und da schauen wir jetzt
dafür
wie vorher erwähnt vor unserer Besatzung
den Fahrrad den Porsche und dann
Kommandanten wir bilden eine mobilen
i-druck das heißt der Fahrer ist im Fall
Leopard der war nämlich der Kommandant
ist der Turm mich und der Bordschütze
ist der Gehilfe Davos den wannenmilch
und den tu mich zur Hand greift wir
haben dort die verschiedensten Werkzeuge
um von der großen Bohrmaschine bis zum
Clan Uhrmacher Schraubenzieher wir
können da theoretisch alles instand
setzen was ist und ich schauen was sie
mal wie die Laden ausschauen
eingeräumt das ist so vom Hersteller
ausgehen ist er mit dem Werkzeug befüllt
und man hat an sauberen Überblick immer
für die ganzen Werkzeuge kommt
so das war das mit der Theorie und wie
es dazu für so haben will ist er Üben
der Leopard gerade draußen hängerbriem
oder Problem und das schauen wir jetzt
da geht schon
[Musik]